a picture from speaker Johnson's youth
where he's standing I I suppose that's
his wife they're taking a picture
together and you may have seen a meme
going around that measures a man's
virility and masculinity by whether or
not he is standing up straight while the
woman in the picture or I guess even the
man in the picture is leaning into him
whoever is leaning the most is the
subservient person in the relationship
and whoever is standing up the
straightest whoever is is most in
composure of himself that would be the
alpha in the relationship this according
to the internet and there's this picture
where Mike Johnson taking a photo with
this beautiful lady who I assume to be
his wife and she is totally leaning in
to Mike Johnson Mike Johnson not only
standing up straight he's actually
leaning back a little bit this is a
degree of Sigma chatty this is a degree
of virility uh here or to for unknown to
scientists and it to me augures well of
what will come in his speakership